the White House press secretary Josh
earnest called vin scully to tell him he
had won the medal of freedom and seen if
you could play at least a portion of
this and then we'll bring in the White
House press secretary who placed the
call well mr. Scully yes hi there my
name is Josh earnest I'm the White House
press secretary my gosh I certainly know
that it is there I'm doing great how are
you nice afternoon oh we're fine well
mr. Scully I know that you you're really
busy I wanted to call and talk to you
about something the every year the
president gives out something called the
presidential medal of freedom it is he
oh yeah it's the highest civilian honor
that any president can give and
President Obama has given it out every
year that he's been in office and he
gives it just to just a handful of
people and this year he's gonna give it
to you oh my gosh no yes so you've had
are you sure well I'm dead an old
baseball announcer well listen you've
had a remarkable impact on the lives of
generations and sports fans in this
country and you have brought a decency
and a professionalism to this job that
hasn't just captured the attention of
generations of Americans it's captured
the attention of the president united
states and you get any money I'm rather
overwhelmed and humbled and very so much
Josh spring in Josh earnest the White
House press secretary who joins us from
Berlin how nervous were you placing that
call there Josh dan I was very nervous
you know you'll get to talk on the phone
to a living legend very often and it was
a great opportunity as a real thrill so
you must be nervous now talking to me I
was just gonna say look here my knees my
knees knocking on the phone now did you
place the call to michael jordan and
kareem abdul-jabbar as well no no just
just a vin scully someone else had the
honor of calling us the other two Hall
of Famers who will be honored next week
at the White House where are you right
now but we are i'm actually in a car we
are driving to were in berlin and we are
driving to the the german chancellor
office where the president will be
sitting down for a an hour-long meeting
with the with angela merkel the
chancellor of germany but you know i'm
also happy to talk about sports too
that's awesome now what is your role
when you have teams come to the White
House well it sort of depends on who it
is usually I don't have much of a role
but when there are teams that have a
little personal interest to me then I
will find a way to insert myself into a
role and earlier this earlier this
summer the Kansas City Royals came to
the White House to celebrate their world
series championship from last year and I
grew up I was born and raised in Kansas
City a lifelong Royals fan and so there
were many Ernest from Kansas City who
are an Intendant of the event and I had
a chance to visit with some of the
players backstage and we had a we had an
amazing time there's really one of my
one of the highlights of my White House
experience what's the president going to
do with all the jerseys he's received
what we've we've actually been talking
about that I suspect that there will be
an amazing display at the future Barack
Hussein Obama Presidential Library as
soon as they get that built there'll be
a whole wing dedicated to those forts
distance I know that he always he's
always enjoyed hosting those teams and
it would be a yeah you can imagine a
whole wall filled with Obama jerseys is
there a sports viewing room if there's a
big game on is there a place where you
guys can go watch at the White House
there's not there's not one that that
that is there regularly early in the
president's tenure glued to the searcher
second year when the bowls the you know
his hometown bowls made a run in the NBA
playoffs and there are a couple of games
that we turned on for staff in the White
House Theatre where people were able to
come by and watch the games and then a
couple of weeks ago for Game seven of
the World Series it actually happened to
be an uncharacteristically warm November
evening in Washington and so they
actually brought out some screens into
the Rose Garden of the White House and
some of the staff was able to come by
and watch up Game seven of the World
Series from the Rose Garden there and I
it was too late for me to stay up that
late to watch it at the office but
but to my colleagues and this had a
really good time cheering on your there
are obviously a lot of chicagoans we
work at the White House a lot of lot of
folks were cheering on their hometown
team there are you allowed to get into a
heated argument with the president /
sports it may be the only topic in which
that is tolerated I don't think he
really isn't a he's that interested in
heated advice of many things but if you
wouldn't have a heated debate with him
about the last night's NBA game he would
welcome the opportunity to do that he's
the Josh earnest the White House press
secretary joining us from Berlin we're
thinking about maybe the Teddy Roosevelt
man cave need so a sports watching room
for presidents future presidents could
President Obama make that happen before
he leaves the White House where he he
has a man cave there well I you know I
my guess is that if he was able to
survive for more than seven years
without a man cave I think that he's
probably just gonna let somebody else
deal with that and he'll make sure you
get to man cave and in the outfit he
listed next if video the president
actually has this routine where he I
don't know you could describe it as a
man cave but there is this there's a
house in the or there's a room in the
residents of the White House where the
president works every evening and he
goes paper working it get television on
the background so I know he's watched
many many big games there as a result of
just haven't had TV on in the background
so I don't feel qualifies as a man cave
yet but it certainly is a place where
he's watched a lot of games if he calls
right now you have to hang up
immediately uh yeah he's actually just a
few cars ahead of me so if they stop and
walk back and I had to abruptly get off
the phone you'll know why would he be
upset if he knew that you were doing
this right now i know i can't wait in
fact i can't wait to tell him that I did
it oh cool just getting ready to do a
you can do this hour-long meeting with
the German Chancellor and then he's
doing a news conference after that so
all the chance to see him before he does
the news conference and he'll be excited
to hear that I was doing something
entertaining well he was working well
congrats on getting the honor to call
vin scully and as you could tell a very
very humble man and you know I'm sure
that he'll be overwhelmed with
motion when he gets that honor yeah he
was he was such a gentleman and you know
you hear a lot about people who've got a
reputation in the public eye for being
you know upstanding individuals and he'd
totally lived up to the hype so he's a
really a really classy guy and I'm
really looking forward to the
opportunity to get a chance to meet him
in person he's at the White House next
week and I know the president is too we
we know that you know time is winding
down there for you know president and
his staff and be kind of nice to get the
danettes my guys to go to the White
House and you know even if it's not to
do a show or anything but you know maybe
on the property something like that Josh
I don't know if you can make things
happen there well they listen there are
there are a lot of journalists who are
at the White House every day there's a
White House briefing room and so if John
jealous we're not internally we're not
journalists we're we're friends we're
friends that's all we had we don't want
to do I night House press briefing or
any of that we want to come and like
just hang out a little bit you come you
come and check that well you know
there's there's not a lot of room at the
white house just for anybody to put
their feet up on the coffee table but if
you if you wanted to bring a couple
years in to check things out I'm sure we
could make that happen maybe we could
just hang in the Rose Garden I'd like I
don't you know maybe throw the ball
around a little bit if if the president
wants to play some hoops I'd be more
than happy to school it I mean play with
the other president do you think you
could make that happen via I don't know
if I could make that happen yeah the
president the president did fulfill his
long-standing Election Day tradition by
playing basketball on Election Day mmm a
selection 8 didn't bring the it didn't
bring the good luck that it has often in
the past unfortunately but but is the
first time the president had played
basketball in a while and he said that
he had to hold back a little bit he
didn't want to show up on television the
next day with a black eye or busted lip
or something well I would let him win if
we played prior to january but after
january then i would probably take no
prisoners and i would have to i'd have
to beat him in a shooting contest so he
would expect nothing but he would not
want you to go easy on him I assure you
that's true good hey Josh thanks for
joining us
and good luck and tell the president we
said hello so thanks D and I appreciate
having me on the show man i'm a big fan
thank you that's Josh earnest the White
House press secretary the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience